sir how are you i'm very good connor i
love you too it's nice to be back it's
been a while i think the last time was
the world's end when i was drunk acting
for you yeah uh
we haven't we haven't chatted in a while
certainly not since this
panda and um i don't even know where to
begin
i mean every interview that i do now
begins with how are you
how are you handling uh this quarantine
how are you doing yeah
um i'm all right i've actually i enjoyed
lockdown to be honest the first
part of lockdown you remember the first
wave it wasn't so bad yes
right um i was in blue side i was fairly
light i was isolated i was at my house i
was writing i was kind of quite
i was nice to have an excuse when your
friend you know when usually you have to
pretend
that you can't come out because the
kid's sick or the dog is
in prison or something and i i was able
to say no i can't come out there's a
global pandemic and i wasn't lying and i
felt great about that
okay but here's the problem i did that
too and i like that because i'm very
anti-social and i like to say
i'd love to be there but there's a
pandemic can't make it now i don't know
if you're having this
problem i'm experiencing this people
that i never talk to that much
ever in my life now say let's hook up on
zoom and talk
and how do you get out of a zoom call
you can't they know you're home
are people i was not close to now
constantly want to zoom
and catch up there must be a conspiracy
theory somewhere that states that the
people behind zoom
created covert 19
to just one of the stock market killing
because
i i'm the same every day there's so
there's a zoom call to do that
you know i i have to say and i'm not the
only one i've been thinking you of you
a lot uh during this uh quarantine
during covid because memes like this
have been popping up constantly
um and like it or not
you are the face of uh
global pandemic and madness breaking out
how do you feel about that
i couldn't be more proud to be honest it
was something i'd always hoped would
happen
you know the funny thing is is that that
meme has popped up through various you
know through brexit and through
other uh you know the re-election of the
tory party whatever has that that's
cropped up at home a lot
and then as as the coronavirus uh began
to
sort of spread it popped up again but
then
we passed the point when going to the
pub was actually allowed
so the meme itself became outdated quite
quickly when going the winchester
was no longer advisable so um nick frost
and i kind of recreated that scene from
sean of the dead we lit i called him one
morning i was on the school run and i
said nick i'm going to send you some
lines
we'll do the thing again but we'll make
it about staying at home
so that's on youtube somewhere that was
in the early stages of the pandemic when
celebrity videos were cool for the for
that two weeks when
they were yeah guess what i miss that
window so i've been shut out of any kind
of celebrity
there was a slight window and i grew up
simon i miss that window just if you've
only got on the imagine